from New York City where police have a
suspect in custody in the brutal
stabbing death of a teenage student the
victim 18 year old Tessa majors was in
her first year at Barnard the Women's
College affiliated with Columbia
University the rattled community held a
vigil for her last night sources tell
CBS News the suspect under arrest is 13
years old
Errol Barnett is at Barnard College
Errol what else do we know at this point
well CBS News has learned the 13-year
old suspect has been charged with
second-degree murder the NYPD says they
were canvassing an area near the crime
scene when they saw this suspect wearing
clothing similar to that of suspects
from the park now this teen had
possession of a knife and admitted to
detectives that he and two friends
robbed Tessa majors and stabbed her I
think this is just kind of a shock
Barnard college students were emotional
Thursday after news emerged their
classmate freshman Tessa majors had been
killed in a park near campus it could
have been anyone it's just so
unfortunate that it happened so young
just before 7:00 p.m. Wednesday police
say majors were stabbed several times by
one two three people after a struggle in
the park she staggered up these steps
into the street where a school security
guard eventually saw her and called 911
all the park is a popular thoroughfare
for many college students who live near
or around campus according to NYPD
statistics crime is up in this park and
the city's murder rate is also up some
eight percent why is the murder rate
higher this year compared to last
despite your best efforts look it's a
question we are asking ourselves
strategically not just it's we feel it
emotionally every single one of us gets
the same reports every morning and
they're not just numbers to us they're
human lives in the 1960s and 70s crime
was so rampant in Morningside Park the
Daily News said locals refer to it as
mugging side Park but in 2001 the New
York Times declared Morningside had
emerged from its nightmare writing quote
children are in the playgrounds
Columbia students routinely settle under
trees to read the community is now left
to mourn a rising star a Virginia native
majors interned at a local newspaper in
high school and was already making a
name for herself at Barnard she was
really kind and really good at guitar a
bass player and singer
mages was part of two bands one recently
put out an album the NYPD says all hands
are on deck to solve this crime idea
that a college freshman at Barnard was
murdered in cold blood is absolutely not
only painful to me as a parent it's
terrifying to think that that could
happen anywhere and we should note that
back in April three women were attacked
near that park on separate occasions we
also want to show you this message that
majors father posted to Facebook just a
few months ago for her 18th birthday he
wrote quote I can't wait to see what the
next 18 years have in store majors would
be on campus right now preparing for a
final exam as the other students are
doing right now instead her parents are
having to make arrangements for her
funeral Tony
they're also sorry for that for that
girl's family I mean thank you very much
you just don't you sent them off to
college it's the next stage of their
life it's disturbing for this to happen
on a college campus or anywhere in
America as the mayor said and as her
father says so much hope you get your
children you were saying to me you used
to walk through that part I used to live
at the bottom of that hill so I was part
of the parks I was a new it had gotten
better it's disturbing to hear that it
may have taken a step back maybe it's
off limits now you're a college student
Arielle thank you very much